parce que notre ville se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
yprema votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
équilibre votre magazine sur
l'environnement tout de suite le
sommaire de ce numéro à trappes
l'association dédale lance une nouvelle
à marcq en compagnie d'un maraîcher bio
nous nous rendrons à leur première
réunion rendez-vous ensuite à choisel
dans la pépinière tuyaux qui vient de
remporter un prix pour sa démarche
environnementale globale enfin nous
partirons à la rencontre des services
techniques de montigny qui collecte et
recycle vos sapins de noël
mais tout de suite nous parlons
gaspillage alimentaire sur ce thème les
chiffres sont alarmants dans l'union
européenne près de la moitié des
aliments sains sont gaspillées chaque
année pour en parler nous nous rendons à
trappes dans les locaux de l'association
y qui propose des ateliers éducatifs sur
les gestes anti gaspillage entretien
caroline cellier bonjour merci de ne
recevoir ici aux locaux dit graines à
travers on parle gaspillage alimentaire
aujourd'hui pourquoi caroline est ce un
problème si grave le gaspillage
alimentaire dans le monde alors c'est
vraiment une problématique majeure comme
au niveau international que national
pour en prendre conscience il suffit de
regarder un peu les chiffres chaque jour
en france ces 20 kg de déchets
alimentaires qui sont jetés par habitant
voilà dans ces 20 kg faut bien se dire
qui à sept kilos qui viennent qui sont
des déchets encore faim des aliments
encore emballés qui n'ont pas été
consommés et à côté de ça on a 13 kg qui
vous êtes des restes de repas alors dans
le monde combien de personnes souffrent
de sous-alimentation aujourd'hui encore
plus de 840 millions donc le problème
reste vaste et on peut voir aussi qu'au
niveau planétaire c'est un tiers de tout
ce qui est produit pour nourrir les gens
qui en fait fini à la poubelle c'est non
caroline aujourd'hui qui peut-on accusée
est ce que c'est nous est ce que c'est
la grande distribution est ce que c'est
la restauration en général qui une
responsabilité partagée voilà on peut
pas jeter la pierre à quelqu'un en
particulier c'est nous c'est la
restauration collective que ce soit dans
des hôpitaux dans des collèges que ce
soit la restauration commerciale aussi
les restaurants dans lesquels on peut se
rendre vous comme moi et c'est aussi
bien sûr la grande distribution quelles
solutions peut-on proposer aujourd'hui
aux gens pour essayer de changer les
choses est ce qu'il ya des gestes anti
gaspillage à adopter
ouais il y en a vraiment énormément qui
sont accessibles à tout à chacun au
quotidien voilà donc ça peut être déjà
canton bacon cyr cantons prévoient
d'aller faire ses courses déjà de
regarder en premier dans cette voie car
on regarde ce qu'on a dans ses placards
on planifie un peu les repas de la
semaine si c'est possible
on se fait une liste de courses du coup
à partir de tout ça et ensuite au
magasin parce qu'on peut faire c'est
déjà tout ce qui est produits frais les
acheter en petites quantités et puis ce
qui est pas mal aussi à faire c'est de
décrypter un peu tout ce qui date limite
de consommation et date limite
d'utilisation optimale des petites un
signe qu'on va trouver sur tous les
produits donc la dlc la date limite de
consommation ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il est important de respecter cela
concernait des produits qui sont très
périssables comme la viande les oeufs le
lait les choses comme ça et dans ces cas
là on voit à consommer jusqu'au mont ça
faut respecter après on peut être un peu
mal ainsi un yaourt à était périmé
depuis quelques jours on peut l'ouvrir
ou le on le sent voilà si s'il n'y a pas
de traces il encore beau ya pas de
soucis qui sent bon on peut le manger
après justement va trouver sur d'autres
produits d'aidé à l'ue au date limite
d'utilisation optimale et ça c'est avec
la mention à consommer de préférence
avant
la fin janvier 2014 par exemple une
mention comme ça ça veut dire qu'on peut
encore manger par exemple le paquet de
gâteaux là jusqu'à 3 voire 18 mois après
la fin janvier 2014 du coup il ya plein
de gens qui vont aller rapidement en
fait ces dates limites et qui pensent
que dès que la date limite est dépassée
ses poubelles non en fait on a vraiment
une petite marge voire une grande marge
avec plusieurs mois voire plus d'un an
de marche pour encore mangé ce paquet de
gâteaux un autre exemple role in c'est
aussi avec des restes ce qu'on peut
confectionner comme menu comme repas au
lieu de jeter de gaspiller
vous avez mis aussi un autre atelier en
place exhaler on encore allez une petite
fiche défi alors imaginez vous êtes papa
d'un petit léo de cinq ans de karine
huit ans auguste 11 ans vous êtes vous
êtes à la maison en famille et la tâche
est ardue
il suffit de il s'agit en tout cas de
consommer un petit repas pour ce soir
est donc vous êtes cinq personnes à 5,5
bouches à nourrir nous avons quelques
restes voilà des restes de la voilà une
petite épicerie de disponibles à la
maison des ingrédients de base farine
sucre huile et compagnie est donc toute
une série de reste alors la queue est ce
que vous demandez aux gens qu est ce que
vous demandez aux gens alors quand vous
leur donnez ça alors on leur demande
tout simplement de s'imaginer un repas
pour cinq personnes à cuisiner avec ses
restes là avec cette base d'épicerie et
éventuellement des courses à aller à
aller faire en supplément d'accord alors
selon l'imagination des gens on se
retrouve avec des idées incroyables de
repas je sais pas si vous aurez ici avez
vous une idée par exemple à partir de 7
heures je vois des joies des courgettes
je vois de la crème fraîche du gruyère
râpé pourquoi pas un petit gratin de
courgettes des pâtes déjà cuites on peut
les faire réchauffer les restes d'un
poulet c'est pareil avant si on aime le
manger froid
je vois du pain rassis du beurre des
pommes et des poires pourquoi pas du
pain perdu par exemple et le sucre des
fruits
il ya plusieurs choses qui sont
disponibles en général c'est quoi la
réponse des gens alors le la compote la
compote a beaucoup de succès une petite
compote de pommes et de poires ça à tous
les coups et on fait beaucoup gratiné
ouais ça on fait gratiné mais le tout
même avec les pâtes les pâtes le poulet
avec les petites courgettes on peut tout
mélanger un petit peu de fromage râpé au
dessus ça passe au four et c'est
tellement vite fait quoi au lieu d'aller
faire des courses en plus donc là en
fait pas besoin d'aller acheter quoi que
ce soit et bien voilà un bel exemple
pour terminer cette explication merci
beaucoup caroline a un prix et écoute et
bonne continuation et surtout continuer
à mobiliser les gens sur le gaspillage
alimentaire merci je vous en prie
après les conseils anti gaspi de
caroline on continue à parler
alimentation intelligente avec la mise
en place d'une nouvelle amap attrape
reportage
une nouvelle amap pour les trappistes ce
week-end salle jean-moulin l'association
dédale organisait une première réunion
d'information pour la vingtaine
d'inscrits favorable au maintien de
l'agriculture paysanne un contrat d'un
an a été signé avec un maraîcher bio
installé à maintenon et les premières
distributions de paniers s'effectueront
dès le mois de mars depuis 2008 on
on défend on promet les alternatives
locales et là bas c'était l'occasion
voilà de porter un projet concret sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
donc voilà donc le principe d'une amap
basse et de mettre en lien des des
consommateurs avec un paysan on voit
qu'ils qui produit les légumes on peut
lui poser toutes les questions le
producteur est vraiment très transparent
donc il ya donc c'est ça c'est assez
sympa et puis aussi l'aspect
convivialité qu'on a pu déjà voir ce
matin une trentaine de légumes
différents en fonction des saisons
seront prochainement mises en production
chaque panier des livres et coûtera 17
euros et permettra de nourrir un couple
avec deux enfants pendant une semaine
c'est un intérêt déjà un intérêt
financier pour le pour le producteur
parce que son revenu fixe et puis sa
production est pré vendu en début de
saison donc
et pour le consommateur c'est un intérêt
aussi parce que c'est ça lui il a des
produits de saison et de qualité et puis
aussi ça crée du lien entre le groupe et
le mile le maraîcher si vous souhaitez
rejoindre le mouvement les inscriptions
sont encore ouvertes durant le mois de
janvier en france on compte aujourd'hui
plus de 1700 amap pour près de 300 en
ile de france
nous prenons maintenant la direction de
choisel dans la pépinière tuyaux
entreprise modèle environnemental
al-abani l'arrosage les pesticides et
les désherbants de sa production anthony
rech patrick jacques de dixmude
une démarche environnementale globale
c'est sur ce principe que fin décembre
les pépinières tuyaux sont récompensés
en devenant lauréat du prix entreprise
environnement 2013 décerné notamment par
le conseil général des yvelines cette
distinction vient saluer le peu d'impact
sur l'environnement et le bilan carbone
positif de cette entreprise de choisel
créances et 150 ici les arbres ne sont
jamais arrosé durant l'année la terre et
bill et au lieu d'être désherber et des
pièges à insectes écologique remplace
les pesticides autre technique utilisée
la mycorhize ation des champignons sont
enfouis sous terre est mise en symbiose
avec les racines ils vont alors grossir
et permettre à l'arbre d'avoir cinq à
dix fois plus d'espacé sous terre pour
se développer ce prix a permis de nous a
permis de vérifier que nos démarches
pour être reconnu et est comprise donc
ça c'est toujours une satisfaction et
après on essaie bien sûr de de prêcher
la bonne parole et de est de faire
comprendre que notre travail de qualité
doit être giresse se transmettre par un
par niveau du prix en termes du coup se
produire en respectant les neurones mans
ça demande quand même beaucoup plus de
main d'oeuvre le fait de montrer qu'on
est très respectueux de l'environnement
permet d'essayer de justifier lentement
un prix qui peut être supérieure à
d'autres entreprises qui sont moins
respectueuse qui utilise plus de
désherbant par exemple comme le circuit
court dans l'agroalimentaire la qualité
environnementale a donc un coup dans
cette pépinière c'est surtout la main
d'oeuvre deux fois plus cher que chez
certains pays concurrents comme
l'allemagne ou l'italie qui augmente les
tarifs à la caisse pour indication si
vous souhaitez acquérir un pommier ou un
tulipier âgés de 12 à 15 ans il vous
faudra débourser entre 400 et 500 euros
à montigny le bretonneux les services
techniques de la mairie collecte et
recycle vos sapins nous les avons suivis
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images
que faire de son sapin après les fêtes à
montigny le bretonneux les services
techniques de la mairie ont organisé
pour la deuxième année consécutive une
collecte pour vous aider à vous
débarrasser de vos conifères
pour ce faire il suffisait de venir
déposer son sapin vierges de toute
décoration sac ou support dans l'un des
19 ans clôt répartis à travers la ville
une démarche écologique puisque les
arbres étaient broyées avant d'être
recyclées
déjà sur la commune de montigny quatorze
mille tonnes de déchets on s'est dit que
l'on pouvait en extraire une partie le
sapin rend service à noël pour les fêtes
laisse la possibilité de prendre un
deuxième service en abondance quale la
terre de nos espaces verts soit en en
emmenant ses sapins pour qu'il soit
composter sur les massifs le produit du
broyage va permettre de garder la terre
humide et d'éviter la pousse des
mauvaises herbes sans utiliser de
traitement chimique l'an dernier 15
mètres cubes de conifères avaient été
collectées soit 1247 sapin cette année
la mairie en comptait déjà plus de 1300
10 janvier une dizaine de jours avant la
fin de la collecte
c'est la fin de ce numéro d' équilibre
mais avant de se quitter on jette un
oeil à l'agenda le vendredi 7 février à
20h30 venez assister à la projection du
film documentaire espèces d'espèces un
film qui nous plonge dans les origines
du monde et nous rappelle que tous les
êtres vivants sont de la même famille le
12 février rencontre débat espèces de
singes venez débattre dans une approche
ludique avec jacques guéry corps au
chercheur au cnrs sur la théorie de
l'évolution la génétique le
créationnisme et même le jeunisme les 18
et 19 et 20 février l'atelier voyage au
pays de darwin propose aux enfants grâce
à des explications simples et amusantes
de comprendre l'évolution incroyable de
certaines espèces voilà pour le
programme environnemental
nous on se retrouve le 21 février
prochain et d'ici là n'oubliez pas la
terre est notre mère respectons la salut